did you help link and clay murder salman  khan oh and all prominent members of his  crime family you're goddamn right I did  oh my head whoo baby whoo baby it's a  long way down way down Marshall largest  number of casualties in the ongoing  conflict if you gets the olivion nur do  disquiet away from here and check the  club before your daddy's good righteous  will rejoice when he sees the Vengeance  gonna come nothing you do or bring any  of them back go to the river where the  water it took me months to figure out  that Lincoln had survived the massacre  was waging a war against salman khan oh  is this crazy on the cross thank you  again Ben you're not a lot  so is never going to be over wanna keep  going you got no more fever make the one  yeah so right now it's just you shot him  once  Oh  LOL